[Music]
after a hundred and sixty miles of
hiking without a trail we'd hoped our
next sections would get easier they
didn't
[Music]
[Music]
with 500 plus miles to go we have to
keep moving
downstream for the next two months we do
just that
hiking 12 hours a day often hunting
water and locating our food caches
strategically stash to advance 50 to 100
miles apart at one spring we stop and
gaze upon its babbling current thirsty
they're reluctant to drink horn creaks
it's below the defunct orphan uranium
mine which operated above us on the rim
until 1969 today the waters in Horn
Creek are still tested to poisonous to
drink it serves as a reminder how
activity on the rim affects the world
below another 150 miles west hiking on
the Tonto bench we exit briefly to visit
park officials at the South Rim to get
the perspective on the state of the
canyon we work really hard in every way
we can to preserve and protect the
integrity of this place and these
outside external threats can only
diminish that this is the most protected
place in the world in terms of the body
of laws that have gone on to protect
this place and yet what do you think I
spend most of my time doing just
protecting this place my job is to
continually raise hell about what's
going on and to make sure that some of
these major developments don't occur
like at Ram's at the bottom of Grand
Canyon the town of to see on and a
mega-resort development
uranium is another one of those threats
has been here since day one it continues
to be we have to work with a number of
groups to make sure that the withdrawal
of uranium mining lands around the park
stay in place forever
by late January the heat we feared in
the fall is long forgotten we recruit
through hiker rich Rudo our pal Kelly
McGrath and Amy Martin a former park
ranger to help shoulder the heavy loads
of food and gear for the winter
challenge ah it's a good thing we do an
Arctic front quickly blows through our
bones making us shiver through long
crisp nights I love the Sun apart
what's but so-called then came the snow
guts the 45 miles an hour
we've got likelihood of snow tonight
tomorrow so we're going to get hammered
pretty good we're running low on sugar
and this we don't keep walking we're not
going to get to our food cache so my big
question is when do I start to panic
right now I don't know how to get my
feet into the bricks of ice
the only way in this attempt to deal
with this is a little bit of warm water
we're putting spikes on our feet some of
these bays are really steep and if you
break loose you can't stop yourself
you're going over the end of the abyss
[Music]
I'd imagine enough potentially 3,000
feet down this is a allies day and was
named for those two incredible you know
hollowed-out eye sockets up there that
look like a big al and in 2012 friend of
ours Alana was walking with Matthias
through here and we don't know exactly
how but Ilana
slipped into the cooler and then just
did a run out for you know 40 or 50 feet
and then over the edge and she fell 400
feet so this place is you know special
to us for remembering her and super spot
for us to camp she would she be thrilled
[Music]
we've made it around the great some past
allies one of the sketchy is to the trip
canine on this leg we brought eight days
of food
I'm definitely got 10 to 90 some both
ankles
[Music]
just a few minutes ago my patella was
very here and I had to do a little bit
of this to get it back into its fresh
place we are super remote so there
really aren't many options little seeing
right here I'm good good
you can't hide out here without a
contingency plan nothing really ever
goes exactly according to plan we're a
perfect example then
[Music]
you
after soldiering through one of the most
remote sections of the canyon we drop
off the okra tinted Esplanade back to
the red wall layer where wild burros
reside and then descend into the magic
of Ollo Canyon
Oh canyons incredibly beautiful and then
when the light changes the reflections
of the potholes just make you think that
you're you know seeing some kind of
divine intervention you should go into
these places it's just my favorite
places in Grand Canyon
I could have spent days studying the
secret to this labyrinth but our
stomachs won't allow it if we don't keep
moving
[Applause]
by early February we emerge from our
coldest hardest leg at Havasu Creek once
again a storm of controversy and debate
on the rim above us could play a hand in
the future of the natural Cathedral and
Springs we walked through mining in and
around the park has been a charged
subject for decades recently it has
ignited again with the reopening of the
Canyon Mine on the South Rim just
outside the park boundary they have a
suit by Native American tribe are some
of the longest inhabitants of Grand
Canyon and they are concerned that a
mining accident might change their world
this is the actual site of the canyon
mine my reservation is about twenty
miles from here and we feel that this
mind behind me is going to contaminate
our ground water source and when it
floods here it goes down to the super
village where 800 members of my tribe
live down there and when this
contamination does reach our home
there'll be no more have a seat Pike
mining that we do out here is heavily
regulated there are major controls for
water protection both ground and surface
water protection which basically means
that no water can enter or exit the site
except through precipitation and even
precipitation that falls on this site is
diverted to a operation pond and it's
evaporated the Spirit is very powerful
you see the rains that have come in to
the east lured there's flooding this bag
overflows and it goes down the ravine it
goes straight into our home and it will
leak into the ground and it will begin
to affect our people's water I'll tell
you from a water standpoint there's a
variety of reasons why we're not
concerned we're well above any sort of a
regional aquifer there's no known
connections from even the bottom of
these mines to the regional aquifers
groundwater is kind of a black box in
science water infiltrates into the earth
and flows in fractures and fault lines
and comes out someplace but really the
path of water through the ground is
quite mysterious and therefore the
trustworthiness of anybody's claim about
the flow directions about the timing of
the flow path the duration of the flow
path of that groundwater needs to be
reviewed everybody in the country wants
all of the positive thinks that energy
gives you your cell phone your computer
your TV your heat your lights everything
that we use runs off of power we didn't
put the uranium here this is the best
place in the United States where uranium
occurs but again with our small-scale
mining that we're doing here I just
don't think that there is any reason to
have any concern for the Grand Canyon
everybody's talking about money
everybody wants to make money our main
concern is our lives
we're talking about human lives here
once again Kevin and I leave a brewing
debate on the surface of the canyon to
tackle our own challenges we have
another 200 miles to go through western
Grand Canyon which some call the gods
scape
[Music]